à marcilly sur tille e coronavirus vient
chambouler les habitudes
plus question de voter ici le local est
trop petit les 1200 aux inscrivent un
devoir se rendre à la salle polyvalente
où toutes les consignes ont pu être
appliqué en urgence
donc la première chose c'est un point
d'eau donc fabriqué maison parce qu'on
n'a pas pu se procurer de gel
hydroalcoolique donc lavabo vont y
aurait le savons il y aura tout ce qu'il
faut dit si d'ici demain matin
ici deux bureaux de vote ont été
installés et là encore les mesures de
protection sont respectées donc on va
rentrer dans le bus roulent donc les
portes vont rester ouvertes à on n'aura
pas il y aura les gens n'auront pas les
toucher donc quand on arrive à
l'intérieur il ya un marquage au sol
on a mis des paravents devant les
isoloirs parce que on a enlevé les
rideaux pour pas que les gens que les
touches on a essayé de faire le maximum
surtout avec le peu de temps qu'on avait
mais voilà tous les services s'y sont
mis et puis voilà donc je pense que ça
va porter ses fruits
amarré sur tille 245 inscrit tout est
prêt aussi gel hydroalcoolique
désinfectant stylo le maire et son
adjoint ont tout fait pour coller aux
directives un drôle de dernier scrutin
quand même pour ferruccio boldrini qui a
décidé de passer la main
on n'a jamais connu ça et donc on est un
petit peu perdues quand même donc un bon
donc après on essaie de s'adapter par
rapport à ce qu'on peut faire et puis
éviter que ça se propage comme donc
voilà c'est c'est notre rôle en tant que
que mr et pillé adjoint aussi et
conseillez quoi
malgré toutes ces précautions pour
éviter une contamination la grande
inconnue ici comme ailleurs reste la
participation